i always love running into you you're so
positive i know we all can't be positive
all the time
and so but i'm just saying but every
time i run into you you're so inspiring
you're so positive you're so sweet
and you're so knowledgeable i think
you're like one of those people that
inspire me when i'm interviewing people
to really like dive in and do my
homework for it
because it matters it makes people i
think you bring your authenticity and
every time kelly and i are together
topher it's so funny i feel like we
immediately go deep
we go to something going on our life we
go to the kids we go to something real
and i love that about you i did too it's
it i love it's
refreshing i don't know if everybody you
know drops their guard all the time and
so
i i know that actually most people don't
go deep what do we want to talk about
you're on a couch lay down topher it's
an interview yeah exactly
just relax here we are well congrats on
all the success
um with access hollywood and access
daily it's been renewed for three more
years
three more years oh congrats yeah that's
awesome right
and what's funny about that i don't know
if anybody here can relate thank you all
for y'all clapping out there is
i got that job at age 40. and you think
about a woman at age 40.
but how is that possible if you're 38
years old now that i'm 32.
uh and at 50 now it's funny to look back
and at the time i had a bunch of stuff
going on in my life and
the joke is that i told my agents to
hold all calls but literally nobody was
calling like nobody was looking for me
the phone was not ringing so i got
access hollywood at age 40
and a decade later i'm here and it got
picked up so it's kind of it's it's a
neat story for me i love that story
because a lot of people especially women
like you said it's
sorry it's a truth that most women at 40
aren't given a
job for us you know like that that's not
a normal thing so i think that that's
really cool and
telling for a lot of people out there
that are watching there may be like
maybe that dream's
gone like i you know i've outlived that
or something and when i got the call for
it
way randomly out of the blue i only went
because as a stay-at-home mom
i just wanted a free trip to california
right away from the three kids
and i'm not kidding i'm like free trip i
watched the movie on the plane
and i was not thinking about this what
did tj maxx got the cutest outfit i
could put together
self-tanned my legs botched the whole
audition i was sweating
my legs were sticking together the
earpiece was popping out probably orange
i was oriented it was a good jergens
that was a nice little color smelled
good
and um it's funny that after the
interview they called me in and i was
like we talked for about three hours i
said oh my gosh do you guys like like me
like i am not moving to california and
here i am yep i'm still here just
waiting for you to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever